你到底想乾嘛
我要把這個
哦
Hudders的
這個其實就叫Hudders
因為你要控制它是做這個職業的
對吧
就是Agent.md 設完了
它就是一個
前班工程師
誒
又沒有這個啊
哦
我幫了多哈
這些
好
所以
所以我剛才其實GitHub上面呢
我已經讓我的Codex啊
去幫我把這個前端的員工給搞下來了啊
一個字沒寫
就說幫我把這個前端搞下來
它就知道我要調甚麼工具
我要甚麼工作要做的
對吧
有甚麼優化性能的維護代碼
必須遵守
性能優先開發
對吧
然後V-act
V-act 甚麼意思啊
它就這架構
V-act 組件
怎麼樣
有V-cent的
然後再Action
等等
它的架構你都可以不用管
它就是把你設好了
這個限制了
然後再寫你的工作流程
對吧
項目搭建和架構
組件開發
性能優化
測試和資料保證
你的交付物就是一個UI
對吧
性能
有甚麼硬條件
這些都是Hunners
就別的
一個前端工程師幫你寫好的一個Hunners
你直接分析了就能用了
然後還有你的溝通風格
各種
這很大的一個文件
其實它就是第一個Hunners
你到底它要幹甚麼
OK
但它只是有
它只是有它的職位的一些功能
但它不知道你公司是乾啥的
所以你先要寫一個秘密
我到底公司是看啥的
要甚麼風格
是甚麼顏色的
品牌長甚麼樣
對吧
再把這個員工請進來
你現在要有公司文化
再有員工才會有團隊啊
團隊才需要管理啊
管理才需要系統啊
對吧
一步步來嘛
OK
好了
接下來其實就是一個簡單的分享
因為這個PPT啊
我是真的燒了六個小時
花了幾十塊美金的token啊
結果真的出來
我一個字沒改
做的很漂亮
那我做的話
我可能做幾個月都做不出來
這種效果啊
因為我畢竟不是PPT專業
但它做PPT我真的佩服
而且它完全能理解我的意思
就我跟它說
到底AI時代產生的這個FDE跟OPC
有甚麼共通點跟區別呢
對吧
它們最後會有甚麼樣的一個發展呢
我就給了它這個問題而已
對吧
它就開始幫我收資料
做美工
最後出這個PPT
但有點凝圖
是跑了六個多小時
我一開始以為它當機了
後面花了我這麼多錢
但是結果我是很滿意的
因為不用改一個字
然後呢
就是說FDE跟OPC呢
就是一個是深入的
最大組織
應該是放大的最小組織啊
所以我們說FDE其實就是幫一些很大的組織
升入到現場去
把它的所有的流程給數據化
然後能夠把AI加進去
來管理一些智能體
把一些重復的工作
對吧
用所調的那家公司很厲害的
待會我們介紹一下
用AI來幫它完成大部分的工作啊
然後最小組織呢
OPC就是我可以快速的寫網上寫後來寫產品
最後看一下有沒有需求
要不要連帶還是直接放棄
所以呢你可以看到啊
深入一個複雜組織
連接業務現場
定義判斷機制
最後形成結果回流
而OPC呢就是我夠快
做很多事情來測試
但是它的底層是一樣的
就是場景
場景是甚麼
數據是甚麼
工具是甚麼
規則是甚麼
反饋是甚麼
最後交付有價值的東西
到底是甚麼
兩個物種一套羅技
只是說不一樣的組織啊
所以你可以看到啊
傳統的那個
那個體驗有非常多這些東西啊
甚麼ERP啊
NEC啊
NES啊
就這種是工廠管理的
這種是企業資源規劃的
這個客戶管理系統
包括一些工廠的
一些傳感器啊
還有文檔啊
這些很分散
傳統的企業就是
哇
沒辦法
很多都是老員工的經驗
對吧
很難
很難去給他數據化啊
好
所以你可以看到啊
FDE是乾嘛的
對吧
以前的顧問呢
是給咨詢的
軟件公司呢
是給一個軟件產品的
但FDE呢
是要跟客戶一起啊
把結果跑出來
而且能夠讓大部分的員工
一起用起來啊
雖然啊
我們可以看到啊
其實FDE在AI之前已經有了
只是
只是AI出來
讓這個東西變得更厲害了
OK
所以現在又活起來了啊
所以技術啊
業務理解
用度共創
和結果責任
這個都是FDE要做的
所以你可以看到啊
傳統的軟件公司
它是為很多客戶來做一種
軟件
一種能力
而FDE呢
是為一個客戶呢
做全面路的多種能力啊
所以我們說現在就是
沒有甚麼通用的軟件的未來
就是個性化軟件的時代
因為開發軟件成本太低太低了
你今天回家
你都可以開發一個工作台
開發一個軟件
對吧
就花了幾十塊Token
然後你還可以為自己
開發多種能力
對吧
你就是自己的FDE
所以你可以看到啊
它這個
就是它怎麼把一些工廠
複雜的一些現狀
把它本體化
數據化啊
包括訂單
飛機
這個是他們最成功的案例
國外的那個
很厲害
做FDE的公司
他們最成功的案例
就把他們的系統
數據
和應用發這些東西的訂單
對象
邏輯
最後動作是甚麼
全部管理起來
然後從生產飛機
OK
排期
零件
等等
缺陷交付
最後從生產飛機
到直接航班管理啊
對
從
從工廠到航空公司
到直接維修等等
全套都是有AI來
看數據
做決策
再實時跟AI對話
怎麼搞這個事情
最後
決策再給到
不同的AI agent
然後人肯定是要最後審核了
到底P4P
這麼貴的維修預算
買一輛新的
還是直接
直接維修呢
對吧
最後有人去判斷了
然後這個Panasonic
也是讓系統維修了
讓系統能夠越變越聰明
這個才是AI
FDE要做的事情
不是光給你購一個系統
是讓這個系統
人越變越聰明
所以我們說FDE就是要走向又大又複雜的組織
往生的去
而OPC就是我們每個人都可以做的
看看身邊有啥需求
趕快開大一個產品
試一下
你給不給錢
給錢
是不是有更多這樣的客戶
拉私運
建網站
最後成立公司
開始收費
所以我說
人呢
現在更多的工作是在選擇問題
判斷
這個才是關鍵
因為財富不是努力的獎賞
是給判斷的一個
真正的獎賞是給判斷的
還有認知
所以人的工作其實更升級了
我就只做判斷
因為以前時薪也是承斷很高的
到現在呢
你可以看看我剛才演示了一大堆
其實從研發設計開發運營都可以
對吧
找一個工程師就可以乾十個人了
現在
現在OPC不是說我能不能做出來
而是這玩意到底有沒有人要
對吧
我做了
我可能做了一百多個產品
最後沒有一個人買單了
所以其實呢
國外有幾個很成功的案例
其實都是跟照片有關的
POOT-O-EI這個
它其實厲害的就是我用最小版本的一些產品
最後實現了整個電路
我開公司收錢
全世界付款
怎麼停止怎麼迭代
我跑通了這個流程
我自己也變工程師了
對吧
最後跑了十二個項目
就一個項目賺錢了
跟照片有關的
第二個中國的這個
它做了一個小光小貓補光燈啊
Apps 到上面可以收到的
它也是做了幾十個產品啊
最後呢發現
有不同的補光顏色拍照
人家是願意付費的
因為市面上沒有這樣的工具
雖然很簡單
但是人家要用的時候就是付費的
有人用過是嗎
點頭
我也不知道啊
這拍照跟我比較少用
反正它就能夠很快速的
把自媒體跟這個產品做起來了
就我分享我怎麼做這個產品的呀
然後用戶真的有很多啊
然後又變成自媒體加產品
好所以呢
!其實今天給大家學的
就是未來的生意
大部分
會往這個方向靠了
要不就是
企業越來越高向
做FDE
系統化
自動化
把AI嵌在這個系統裡面
裡面大部分是AI員工
再來的就是OPC
我所有的執行都是AI做的
我只要快速試錯
做出一個好產品
最後能夠有人買單
我再把它
往上去升行
所以呢
真正的Agent boss
你既能把你自己很熟悉的
一個業務做得很深
也能快速的把其他產品
能夠跑起來看看
這個才是我們
真的要去花長時間去
深入去做的事情
所以呢
我最後也給大家送的一個東西非常好的
我也是讓AI給我收的
就MIT的一個課程
它裡面呢
包括90天的一個路線
我也是一個字沒寫
就是讓AI寫的
但我覺得這個課件我看過
寫的非常好
就怎麼樣
從第一周
我怎麼建一個小Agent
到後面怎麼變Agent團隊等等
所以不要看
我在這裡講課可能真的水平一般般
但是我講過
所有的環節
講基礎我不行
就是做AI的助教
對吧
講這些知識點
我不好講
我就做成文件
大家回去看
以後有甚麼問題呢
也可以再問我
但是呢
我給大家做百分百的準備
這都是AI用三百個小時逃出來的
對
差不多吧
反正
都可以少很多
沒有全套的
你們報名的網站
到這個知識網站
到我的視頻Agent
對吧
等等等等
你就是這個MIT的課程嗎
就在這裡啊
給的名字給你們嗎
誒
我看看啊
就是你起的名字叫MIT
不是啦
是美國那個MIT學院啊
對啊
對我只是把它變成了中文
把它重點弄下來了
對
那就可以去去
就這兩個
就你可以
你也可以拿Agent search
去search
反正我就是search
對吧
這個課可能會來很多企業家啊
或者已經會用AI的人了
那他們上我這個課
後面想要實操的話
你有甚麼好的課借給我啊
之類的
那他就全網說
Agent Reach
他說MIT的這幾個課程很適合哦
他就給我了
那我就說
那你幫我用到這個網站裡面
等等
OK
所以其實關鍵的不是你來聽了甚麼課
而是說我學到一些概念有起發了
我知道步驟了
回去真的去不斷的執行
中文字幕提供的執行 稍的都肯越多 你才能學的越快啊
所以我今天的分享就到這裡啊
很感謝大家真的 又從香港上來啊 又從各地過來啊
很感謝大家真次的支持啊
好 那我今天分享就到這 謝謝你們
指劍
然後接著
好就到我來了
然後剛其實看著大家非常的夢圈
然後我們現在留一點點時間
其實我們這次課程的已經是完全完整了
然後呢接下來的一些
是為瞭解決一些技術的科學上網問題
甚至剛剛對於全老哥講的名詞
聽不懂呢
也可以再提問一下
就在這個網站上
除了有些視頻
視頻沒有
就是我發到群里
群公告里的呀
對呀
就我把所有的知識點都放在這個網站了
不要再問我資料在哪裡了
我現在很繁盛的事情
好不好
就是有人甚麼發一個PDF到群
外面都會很生氣
因為我已經弄好
OK
對
對,我們這樣可以
我聽會可以
哎呀,慢慢講
那可以啊
對
因為我半年已經肯定要講
聽聽
聽聽聽
聽聽聽聽
就說實在話
程序員的一個特徵是不善言辭
那像Channel哥 懂技術的人 又啃講的人其實還蠻少
但是他的確實有點快
所以大家有問題的話可以隨時問 沒問題
有否不明白 從誰開始聽不明白 一定不明白的
好 請一請 一定請
其實你做不到 有一種事情是情常的 各個會有偏差不出奇的